es ist tatsächlich ein tragischer unfall
der sich hier heute morgen abgespielt
hat die beiden brüder prämien der 13 und
hassan der 70er bruder wollten noch
schnell die bahn in richtung landshut
erwischen haben dann wohl eine
geschlossene schranke überqueren wollen
und haben den zug übersehen der nach
münchen gefahren ist der hat sie dann
erfasst und auf der stelle getötet und
dazu kann ich jetzt auch die weiteren
fragen stellen an dem polizeisprecher
günter thomas co vom polizeipräsidium
niederbayern herr thomas cook was können
sie sagen
wie hat sich das hier abgespielt ja das
ganze hat sich heute morgen früh gegen 7
uhr abgespielt zwei schüler 13 und 17
jahren hier aus der gemeinde bruckberg
die wollten einen zug nach land so noch
erwischen dieser zug
der stammt bereits hier am bahnhof in
bruckberg und haben dazu geschlossene
schranke überquert und sind dann von
einem regionalzug der in richtung
münchen gefahren ist durch den bahnhof
durch hier am bahnübergang erfasst und
tödlich verletzt worden
wenn sie sagen wir haben sich die
ermittlungen vor ort gestaltet das ist
ja auch für die einsatzkräfte eine
enorme belastung so was wenn es auch
gerade jugendliche sind es ist immer
schwieriger einsatz eher belasten der
einsatz
derartige einsätze wenn menschen ums
leben kommen oder hier 13 und 17 jährige
junge burschen
es sind entsprechende
betreuungsmaßnahmen uhr vor ort in die
wege geleitet worden
für die pendler für schüler die das
ganze auch die ober auch die tauben es
waren statisten interventionsteam und
seelsorger etc
auch vor ort um die betreuungsmaßnahmen
aber auch der angehörigen die dann
später zur unfallörtlichkeit gekommen
sind zu gewährleisten
jetzt kommt sowas ja ab und zu oder ein
unbedingtes in abständen häufiger vor
dass angeschlossenen bahnübergängen dann
solche natürlichen unfälle passieren
können sie da einen hinweis geben was am
menschen zu beachten
also bahnübergänge absolut tabu zu
erklären wenn die schranke geschlossen
ist oder wenn rotes blinklicht on ist
oder die bahnübergänge ganz oder die
bahnstrecke außerhalb der regulären
übergänge zu überqueren
wie geht es jetzt weiter die diesen die
weiteren ermittlungen aus
die polizei die kripo landshut hat vor
ort die ermittlungen übernommen und in
absprache mit der staatsanwaltschaft in
landshut werden die ermittlungen
entsprechend geführt
mit den worten des polizeisprechers
günter thomas co vom polizeipräsidium
niederbayern zurück nach berlin
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren